One of the other techniques that's often accompanied by using the separate alpha
workflow is something called RGB mask packing. What this means is taking
different textures and putting them in the red, green, and blue channels of a
texture. While you can utilize the alpha inside of that texture, remember
alphas make textures take two times the amount of memory because that
information is uncompressed. So unless it's absolutely positively needed to
have information that comes in at full resolution, I highly recommend you just
use the red, blue, and green channels of a texture. Inside of the editor, once you've
imported that texture, make sure under the texture settings that you do things
like set compress without alpha to make sure that any alpha information is
removed, and you set the compression settings to masks, no sRGB, and that sRGB
is disabled. Now the reason that I bring this up and what makes it a big
point about it is when you actually bring a masked texture in and set it up
originally, it's actually going to work right out of the box, and we can see
this demonstrated in the screen in front of us on the left-hand side with
the incorrect version. If we look at this bush, it actually looks pretty good.
It doesn't actually look like anything is wrong, but upon closer inspection,
especially if we zoom in in the area that's highlighted, this area is
actually missing a fair bit of detail. Now on the right-hand side, we have the
correct version, which is the same texture just with sRGB disabled, and
notice in the zoomed-in area, we actually have a lot more branch
information there that is actually just completely missing in the other
image. And again, remember, sRGB is disabling gamma correction, so if we
utilize our masked textures with gamma correction enabled, we're actually going
to be changing that data. We're going to be raising its luminosity, and we
don't want that. Remember, masks define where something should or should not be,
so we always want that information to stay the same, and that's why it's so
important to make sure that on any of our masks that we're using that we have
this disable sRGB, as this is going to help us get a better result from
our RGB mask packing workflows.